Leben auf dem sozialen Existenzminimum
Man reduziert alles
ein bisschen aufs Überleben.
Aufs Essen und
dass die Rechnungen bezahlt sind.
(Frau) Wenn ich jemandem sagen muss,
ich sei der Sozialhilfe,
schäme ich mich.
(Frau) Ich würde viel lieber
arbeiten und hätte genügend Geld.
Doch Kritiker sagen,
die Sozialhilfe sei zu hoch.
Man kann leben, man kann überleben,
man muss keine Steuern bezahlen,
keine Wohnung ...
Man hat so das Vorurteil,
dass es einem zu gut geht
mit der Sozialhilfe.
... keine Krankenkasse -
das bezahlt alles das Sozialamt.
Da geht es einem doch viel besser
als einem Familienvater,
der arbeiten gehen muss.
Die Sozialhilfe
ist politisch unter Druck geraten.
Treibende Kraft ist die SVP.
Es darf nicht interessant sein,
Sozialhilfe zu beziehen.
Die Sozialhilfekosten
drücken aufs Budget der Gemeinden,
in den Kantonen sind
radikale Kürzungsvorschläge hängig.
Bei den sozial Schwächsten
hat man gerade das Gefühl,
jede Kürzung sei tragbar,
ohne hinzuschauen,
sich dessen bewusst zu sein,
was das heisst.
Um die Sozialhilfe
tobt ein politischer Kampf.
Ist sie zu bequem für die Betroffenen
und zu teuer für die Allgemeinheit?
Wie sieht die Realität aus und warum
will eines der reichsten Länder
der Welt bei den Ärmsten sparen?
Karin de Roche, 44.
Sozialhilfeempfängerin.
Jeder kann in diese Lage kommen.
Man sollte nicht denken,
es treffe nur die anderen.
Das kann sehr schnell gehen.
Menschen wie wir, wie meine Familie,
verschwinden einfach.
Wir sind im alltäglichen Leben
nicht wirklich sichtbar.
Man hat ja kein Schild:
"Ich beziehe Sozialhilfe."
Hallo.
Was? Taschenlampe? Hast du sie?
Karin de Roche ist alleinerziehende
Mutter von vier Kindern.
Kiyan, der Jüngste, ist behindert.
Gib Mami die Hand, bitte! Wir gehen.
Ein Drittel aller Sozialhilfebezüger
sind Kinder.
Hast du gesehen?
Fast wie ein Rasenmäher.
Die Familie
wohnt in Mosen am Hallwilersee.
Hier gibt es günstige Wohnungen.
Bis das dritte Kind zur Welt kam,
hat Karin de Roche als
Behindertenbetreuerin gearbeitet.
Pause.
- Ja, Pause.
Super.
Jetzt gehst du sitzen?
- Sitzen.
Sitzen, essen.
Setzt du dich dorthin? Okay.
Nein ... Kiyan,
setzt du dich bitte gerade hin?
Kiyan hat einen Gendefekt.
Das, was man am meisten merkt,
ist der Wasserkopf -
wie man dem umgangssprachlich sagt,
Hydrocephalus.
Er hat im Köpfchen einen Shunt,
der das Hirnwasser
ins Bäuchlein ableitet.
In den Bauch.
Autismus hat er auch.
Ja, also ein wenig ...
Er hat vieles.
Gweni.
- Gweni ist in der Schule.
(Deutlich) Schule.
Seit Kurzem ist Kiyan
drei Nächte pro Woche im Internat.
Trotzdem will Karin de Roche
keine Arbeit suchen.
Ich bin trotzdem
die Hauptbezugsperson für ihn
und habe die Verantwortung.
Wenn er krank ist
oder irgendwelche Termine hat,
wird das nicht von der Schule
übernommen. Das muss ich machen.
Der Sozialdienst
akzeptiert diese Begründung.
Mami, T-Shirt.
- Ein Pulli.
T-Shirt.
- Nein, Pullover.
Karin de Roche, eine von 278'000
Sozialhilfebezügerinnen und -bezügern
in der Schweiz.
Das sind 3,3 % der Bevölkerung.
Alleinerziehende sind eine wachsende
Gruppe in der Sozialhilfestatistik.
Es spiegelt sich
der gesellschaftliche Wandel.
Wer Sozialhilfe bezieht,
spricht nicht gern darüber,
schon gar nicht vor der Kamera.
Karin de Roche aber will reden,
stellvertretend für viele.
Man kann nicht am
gesellschaftlichen Leben teilnehmen.
Das, was für andere Normalität ist,
ist für uns etwas Besonderes.
Spontan shoppen oder was essen oder
trinken gehen, einen Kaffee trinken,
mit den Kindern
einen Ausflug machen,
das muss alles geplant werden.
Das muss ich Anfang Monat wissen,
damit ich es einplanen kann.
Mit vier Kindern ein Zugbillett -
selbst wenn man
die Verpflegung mitnimmt -,
es ist immer noch teuer genug.
Und ja, dann ist man mehr daheim
und macht Aktivitäten
von daheim aus.
Ferien?
Ferien ...
Dann stellen wir
das Zelt im Garten auf
und übernachten ab und zu im Garten.
Leider nein. Ferien
liegen nicht drin. Das ist klar.
Karin de Roche schläft im Wohnzimmer.
Die fünfköpfige Familie
mit zwei Töchtern im Teenager-Alter
lebt
auf dem sozialen Existenzminimum.
Das sind um die 2'300 Fr., 2'380.
Das ist der Grundbedarf,
den wir fürs Leben haben.
Für einen Fünf-Personen-Haushalt.
Miete und Krankenkasse wird dann
natürlich noch dazu berechnet.
Aber zum Essen und Leben
ist das der Betrag.
Alimente und Hilflosenentschädigung
gehen direkt ans Sozialamt.
Karin de Roche
bleibt nur der Grundbedarf.
Für fünf Personen sind das 2'380 Fr.
Gut 15 pro Tag und Person.
Für Lebensmittel, Kleider,
Handy, Zug und Bus z.B.
Für eine Person liegt der Grundbedarf
bei 986 Fr.
Ist dieser Betrag zu hoch
oder zu tief?
Das ist die politische Frage.
Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Die Diskussion um Kürzungen
macht Karin de Roche Angst:
Es reicht wirklich gerade zum Essen,
zu mehr nicht.
Und das auch mit Verzicht.
Bitte schön.
- Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Die Sozialhilfe, einst als Fürsorge
für die Ärmsten im Land gedacht,
ist unter Beschuss geraten.
Tatsächlich
sind die Kosten in wenigen Jahren
von 1,7 auf 2,6 Mrd. gestiegen.
Sie will radikal kürzen:
Therese Schläpfer,
SVP-Gemeindepräsidentin
und ehemalige Sozialvorsteherin
von Hagenbuch im Kanton Zürich.
Es war mein Ressort,
dadurch kam ich dazu.
Da habe ich viele Ungerechtigkeiten
festgestellt.
Therese Schläpfers Dorf
hat 1'100 Einwohner.
Seit 25 Jahren
wohnt sie in Hagenbuch.
Mir gefällt die Grösse des Dorfes
bzw. es ist schön klein.
Es ist schön gelegen.
Man hat Platz und Luft zum Atmen.
Man kennt einander noch.
Das ist schon noch schön.
Das Dorfleben sei hier noch intakt,
sagen die Einheimischen.
(Frau) Das ist eben noch Landleben.
Da hat es noch Leute, die helfen.
Es ist eben urchig.
- Ja, das ist es.
Zwei Beizen hat es in Hagenbuch,
eine Hauptstrasse mitten durchs Dorf,
einen Lebensmittelladen,
ein paar Kleinunternehmen
und Landwirtschaftsbetriebe.
Hallo zusammen.
Vor fünf Jahren
wurde die Idylle gestört.
Therese Schläpfer
gab den Medien offen Auskunft
über die Sozialhilfekosten
der Gemeinde.
Auslöser war eine siebenköpfige
Familie aus Eritrea.
Von Sozial-Irrsinn und
exorbitant hohen Kosten war die Rede.
Die Geschichte lief aus dem Ruder.
Therese Schläpfer musste präziseren.
Denn: Längst nicht alle
Sozialhilfekosten der Familie
musste die Gemeinde tragen.
Der Mechanismus
ist relativ kompliziert.
Ich sagte auch: Am Schluss ist es
der Steuerzahler, der es bezahlt.
Trotz der Misstöne damals -
die Gemeindepräsidentin
würde wieder gleich handeln.
Das ist eigentlich der Fall,
der mich dazu bewogen hat,
näher hinzuschauen,
ob man etwas in die andere Richtung
bewirken kann.
Therese Schläpfer ist nicht allein.
Sie gehört
zu einer SVP-Arbeitsgruppe,
welche die Sozialhilfe
umkrempeln will.
Der Kopf der AG Sozialhilfe:
alt Nationalrat Ulrich Schlüer.
Wo müssen Sie hin?
- Zur SVP.
SVP, kommen Sie rein.
Ulrich Schlüer
hält die Fäden zusammen
und organisiert
alle paar Monate ein Treffen.
Heute im Parteisekretariat
der SVP Zürich, in Dübendorf.
Also, angefangen hat es damit,
dass ich festgestellt habe,
dass die Frage der Steigerung,
z.T. eine Explosion
der Sozialhilfekosten,
grosse Unruhe auslöst.
Dann habe ich festgestellt,
dass in der SVP so und so viele
Frauen und Männer sind,
die in ihrer Gemeinde
z.T. stark oder sogar sehr stark
mit dieser Frage konfrontiert sind.
So entstand
die Arbeitsgruppe Sozialhilfe.
(Frau) Hoi.
- Grüezi.
Über 20 SVP-Mitglieder aus der
Deutschschweiz sind darin vertreten.
Sali, Ueli.
- Sali.
An diesem Abend
will man einen Sonderparteitag
auf nationaler Ebene vorbereiten.
Nicht alle wollen sich filmen lassen.
Zu heikel, heisst es.
Dort sitzen die,
die nicht ins Bild wollen.
Das ist mir egal.
- Dann setz dich dorthin.
Ich bin bekannt
wie ein roter Hund im Baselbiet.
Die Gruppe
will einen Abbau der Sozialhilfe.
Einen Masterplan gibt es nicht.
Dafür viele Ideen.
Vorstösse aus dem Baselbiet
geben die Richtung vor.
Aber ausgerechnet der Verfasser
fehlt heute.
Kommt Riebli?
-Ich habe ihn nicht mehr gesehen.
Wir hatten keine Sitzung.
Peter Riebli,
Baselbieter SVP-Landrat,
hat die schweizweit
radikalste Forderung aufgestellt:
Er verlangt, dass der Grundbedarf
bei allen Sozialhilfebezügern
um 30 % aufs absolute Existenzminimum
gesenkt wird.
Das bedeutet:
eine Umkehr des Systems.
Heute gilt: Der Grundbedarf von 986
Fr. kann bei Sozialhilfeempfängern,
die nicht kooperieren,
um 30 % gekürzt werden.
Der Vorschlag von SVP-Mann Riebli
will das Gegenteil:
Alle Sozialhilfebezüger
sollen unten anfangen,
und nur wer kooperiert,
kriegt wieder mehr.
Motivation statt Repression,
so der Titel.
Der Vorschlag hatte Erfolg:
Die Motion Riebli
wurde mit Unterstützung der FDP
knapp gutgeheissen.
Die Kantonsregierung Baselland
muss handeln.
Der Baselbieter Landrat Andi Trüssel
steht voll hinter dem Vorstoss.
Das ist einer der Wege.
Es darf nicht lukrativ sein,
Sozialhilfe zu beziehen.
Wenn die Kritiker sagen ...
- Die Kritiker.
Das ist immer das Gleiche.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Der Regierungsrat muss etwas
ausarbeiten und wir beraten es.
Was ärgert Sie
in Ihrer Gemeinde am meisten?
Dass wir bei 30 % Ausländeranteil
60 % Ausländer
in der Sozialhilfe haben.
Das ärgert mich am meisten. Doppelt
so viele, wie wir Bewohner haben.
Durch das Heruntersetzen
des Grundbedarfs
bekommt man die aus der Sozialhilfe?
- Vielleicht, das werden wir sehen.
Spart man so Kosten?
- Das wird sich weisen.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Geht es nicht ums Sparen?
- Nein.
Wir brauchen ein System, in dem es
uninteressant ist, drinzubleiben.
Das reicht jetzt.
Danke. Schönen Abend.
Es geht nicht nur ums Sparen.
Ziel ist es, die Sozialhilfe
so unbequem wie möglich zu machen.
Zudem stört sich die Arbeitsgruppe
an der Höhe
des gesamten Sozialhilfebetrags,
also Grundbedarf
mit Miete und Krankenkasse.
Es gibt Leute,
die 5'000 Fr. mit einem
Vier-Personen-Haushalt bekommen.
Einige bekommen mit einem
Fünf-Personen-Haushalt 5'500 Fr.
Man kommt wahrscheinlich
nicht darum herum,
einen Teil des Grundbedarfs
zu kürzen.
Es gibt sie, die Zwei-Eltern-Familien
mit so hohen Bezügen.
Laut Bundesamt für Statistik machen
Familien mit zwei und mehr Kindern
5,9 % aller Fälle aus.
Es geht heute darum, dass der
Vorschlag, den wir gemacht haben -
aus der letzen Sitzung ...
Wie die Forderungen
für den nationalen Sonderparteitag
genau aussehen, ist noch unklar.
Einig sind sich aber alle
hier in diesem Raum:
So kann es mit der Sozialhilfe
nicht weitergehen.
In Bern treffen wir Felix Wolffers,
Co-Präsident der Schweizerischen
Konferenz für Sozialhilfe SKOS.
In der SKOS sind alle Kantone
und viele Gemeinden vertreten.
Mit Kürzungsideen
kann er gar nichts anfangen.
Es gibt doch einen Teil der Leute,
die den Anschluss
an die Wirtschaftsentwicklung
nicht mehr geschafft haben,
die evtl. schlecht qualifiziert sind
und gesundheitliche Probleme haben.
Mit diesen Leuten
waren wir bisher immer solidarisch.
Und jetzt
bricht die Solidarität auf.
Der Treiber
ist ganz eindeutig die SVP,
die versucht,
die Solidarität aufzubrechen.
Aus Gründen,
die mir nicht klar sind.
Denn wenn man die Leute
gesellschaftlich ausgrenzt,
wird das Folgekosten haben.
Wir werden mehr Verwahrlosung
und mehr psychische Probleme haben.
Mehr Kriminalität.
Und das kann man nicht wollen.
Ich frage mich:
Was steckt hinter diesen Zielen?
Auch Wolffers ist besorgt über
die Kostenzunahme in der Sozialhilfe.
Ein Bericht des Bundes
liefert Erklärungen:
So sind die Ausgaben für Mieten
und Krankenkassen stark gestiegen,
was sich
in der Sozialhilfe niederschlägt.
Und auch wenn die Zahl
der Sozialhilfebezüger
prozentual kaum gestiegen ist,
so hat das Bevölkerungswachstum
doch eine Zunahme der Fälle bewirkt.
In Hagenbuch
seien die Sozialhilfekosten
in den letzten Jahren
stets gestiegen,
sagt Gemeindepräsidentin
Therese Schläpfer.
Hallo zusammen.
16 Personen
beziehen hier Sozialhilfe.
Das sind weniger
als 2 % der Einwohner.
Hast du kurz Zeit?
- Ja, ist gut.
Für die Betreuung zuständig
ist Yvonne Ball.
Seit acht Jahren ist sie
Sozialsekretärin in Hagenbuch.
Sie ist Kontrollinstanz, Coach
und Betreuerin in einer Person.
Denn manchmal
wird ja nicht alles gesagt.
Genau, aber sie bringen es mir.
Frau Ball hat eine Schlüsselstelle.
Mit ihr steht und fällt
die Betreuung eines Klienten.
Sie macht die Betreuung intensiv.
Ja, sie geht tief ins Private,
die Kenntnis.
Sie hat ein ganz ausgeprägtes
Einfühlungsvermögen.
Am Anfang denkt die Person,
die kommt:
"Was ist das für eine,
was will die alles von mir?"
Dann kommen sie,
machen den Schritt, wollen Geld,
und wir wollen
so viele Unterlagen von ihnen.
Das ist halt schon etwas
kompliziert, bis sie mal drin sind.
Aber wir müssen alles gut prüfen.
Das ist halt wichtig.
Einmal aufgenommen,
gilt die Kooperationspflicht.
Sozialsekretärin Ball
macht nicht nur gute Erfahrungen.
Ich habe einen Termin beim Zahnarzt
vereinbart.
Ich frage den Klienten und er sagt:
"Ich musste in der Schule
eine Prüfung schreiben."
Ich dachte: "Nein, so nicht."
Am Schluss stellte sich raus,
dass er wieder schlafen ging.
Und das ist etwas, das nicht geht.
Hier ging es um Geld.
Der Zahnarzt hat gewartet.
Wir mussten den Termin
dann bezahlen.
Das sind Sachen ... Dann gehen
wieder Steuergelder flöten.
Was machen Sie dann? Wird da gekürzt?
Oder mit Kürzung gedroht?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Aber es ist halt mein Naturell,
dass ich dann auch helfe.
Und vielleicht ...
Mehr Sachen, als ich müsste.
Nicht finanziell.
Sind Sie immer einig,
wie man vorgeht?
Nein.
Sie sagt manchmal, ich sei zu hart.
Also, nicht zu hart,
aber das sei nicht gesetzeskonform.
Ich sage dann einfach ...
Manchmal hätte ich auch Ideen,
wie wir es
unbürokratisch machen könnten.
Aber dann muss ich auch sagen:
"Wir müssen es
von Gesetzes wegen so machen."
Ja, sie holt mich dann
jeweils wieder runter,
und ich muss dann sagen:
"Du hast recht."
Sie müssen die Gemeindepräsidentin
in die Schranken weisen?
Nein, so kann man das nicht sagen.
Der Sozialdienst in Hagenbuch
und in Bern.
Hier betreuen gut 70 Sozialarbeiter
6'500 Klientinnen und Klienten.
Felix Wolffers
ist neben seinem Amt bei der SKOS
auch Chef des Stadtberner Sozialamts.
Es gibt keine Behörde, die so viele
Daten sammelt wie die Sozialhilfe.
Die Leute werden durchleuchtet
in ihrer persönlichen
und finanziellen Situation.
In Bern gibt es spezialisierte Teams
für junge Erwachsene,
für Suchtproblematik oder für Leute,
die wenig Betreuung brauchen,
wie alleinerziehende Mütter.
Auf einen Sozialarbeiter kommen hier
im Schnitt 100 Sozialfälle.
In allen Städten ist die Quote
der Sozialhilfeempfänger höher
als auf dem Land.
Das fordert
andere Strukturen im Sozialamt.
Wir differenzieren,
je nach Beratungsbedarf.
Also bei den jungen Erwachsenen
ist das Ziel,
dass die unter allen Umständen
eine Ausbildung machen.
Dort haben wir
reduzierte Fallzahlen,
dort haben wir 70-90 Fälle
pro Sozialarbeiterstelle.
Und dort ist eine relativ
intensive Betreuung möglich.
In den andern Teams haben wir
eine weniger intensive Beratung.
Sozialarbeiterin Rahel Bräm
betreut Erwachsene ab 25.
Und wie geht's?
Super. Habe im Schnitt eine Fünf.
Perfekt.
Mehr kann ich nicht verlangen.
Kilian Steffen steckt mit 28 Jahren
in einer Lehre als Polymechaniker.
Für diese Zeit ist er
auf die Sozialhilfe angewiesen.
Dann bräuchten wir einfach noch
Kontoauszüge von März bis August.
Das ist die Überprüfung
des Sozialhilfeanspruchs.
Das gibt es bei allen Klienten
einmal pro Jahr.
Und da muss der Klient angeben:
Wie viele Leute wohnen im Haushalt,
was haben sie für Bankkonten,
Kontoauszüge der letzten sechs
Monate, die letzte Mietzinsquittung,
Heiz- und Nebenkosten-Abrechnung
und halt ob sie Löhne hatten,
die sie nicht angegeben haben.
Und Fahrzeuge.
Für die neuen Stipendien
brauchen wir Angaben Ihres Vaters.
Die wären schon
auf dem anderen gewesen.
Das muss man immer neu machen.
Und er muss wieder unterschreiben,
wie Ihre Mutter auch.
Ist das möglich?
Das ist möglich.
Mittlerweile habe ich Kontakt.
Die Eltern
können finanziell nicht helfen.
Lehrlingslohn und Stipendien
reichen aber nicht ganz.
Die Sozialhilfe überbrückt,
eine Investition in die Zukunft.
Weil es immer noch das Beste ist,
eine Ausbildung.
Ich habe lange temporär gearbeitet.
Das ist gut und recht.
Man verdient schön und alles.
Aber auf lange Sicht
ist es nicht das Wahre.
Auch der Kanton Bern
spart in der Sozialhilfe.
Es ist der erste Kanton,
der sich beim Grundbedarf
nicht an die SKOS-Richtlinien hält
und 8 % gekürzt hat.
Das letzte Wort hat nun das Volk.
Ja, da werde ich etwas sauer.
Ich finde, unsere Klienten ...
Das Geld ist knapp,
aber die können damit leben.
Und wenn ich an Kürzungen denke,
kann ich das nicht mehr sagen.
Das würde den Druck enorm erhöhen.
Und ich finde es traurig,
dass in unserem Land
so ein Druck ausgeübt wird
und man das Gefühl hat,
in anderen Bereichen könnte man
gerade so viel Geld herausholen.
Ein Fall aus dem Kanton Aargau zeigt,
wie Gemeinden
schon heute kürzen können.
Am Kantonsspital hat sich Monika Senn
von einer Rheuma-Spezialistin
untersuchen lassen.
Auf Geheiss des Sozialamts.
Diagnose hat sie noch keine.
Jetzt muss das Sozialamt
etwas Geduld haben.
Sie schrieb mir einen Bericht,
ich hätte nach dem MRI
wieder einen Termin bei ihr.
Dann sehen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Monika Senns Schmerzen
sind chronisch.
Die Arbeit als Kassierin
hat sie deswegen längst aufgegeben.
Sieben Jahre
war Senn schon in der Sozialhilfe,
als das Sozialamt letzten Juni neue
medizinische Abklärungen verlangte -
per Verfügung.
Obwohl Senn gerade erst
von Brustkrebs genesen war.
Das Sozialamt ihrer Wohngemeinde
Oberentfelden will klären,
ob Senn wirklich aus medizinischen
Gründen nicht arbeiten kann.
Und sie fordert, dass die Klientin
in eine günstigere Wohnung zieht.
Ich hatte einen Riesenschock,
als ich die Verfügung bekam.
Weil man von mir verlangt,
dass ich aus der Wohnung raus muss.
Das wäre ganz schlimm für mich.
Denn ich müsste dann
wieder eine Wohnung finden,
in der ich
nicht Treppen steigen muss.
Der Umzug
wäre eine Katastrophe für mich.
Den ganzen Hausrat zusammenpacken.
Das ginge gar nicht
wegen der Schmerzen.
Die Gemeinde will zum Fall Senn
nicht direkt Stellung nehmen,
weil der noch hängig sei.
Aber wir erfahren, warum es
eine neue Verfügung gegeben hat:
Im Sozialamt
wurde personell aufgestockt.
Wir haben
eine neue Leitung bekommen,
jetzt gehen wir über die Bücher,
überarbeiten die Dossiers.
Wir haben die Mietzinsrichtlinien
angepasst, das kann Einfluss haben.
Und Leute, die nicht
oder wenig kooperativ sind,
denen werden
die Sozialhilfeleistungen gekürzt.
Es sind enorme Kosten, die wir
tragen müssen, das tut einfach weh.
Monika Senns 3-Zimmerwohnung
kostet 1'023 Fr.
und lag schon immer über
der Mietzinsrichtlinie der Gemeinde,
die im letzten Jahr
noch einmal gesenkt wurde -
von 900 auf 850 Fr.
Damit ist Monika Senns Wohnung
173 Fr. zu teuer.
Bisher trug das Sozialamt
die Mehrkosten.
Jetzt wird ein Strich gezogen.
Wenn Senn nicht umzieht, muss sie
selber für die Differenz aufkommen.
Monika Senn
will die Verfügung nicht akzeptieren.
Jetzt habe ich Einsprache erhoben.
Ich hoffe auf Erfolg,
dass ich nicht so ausgeliefert bin.
Die Hagenbucher Gemeindepräsidentin
Therese Schläpfer ist überzeugt,
dass es Druck braucht:
Die Sozialhilfe sei zu attraktiv.
Der Grundbedarf
von 986 Fr. pro Person
könne problemlos
um einen Drittel gesenkt werden.
Es gibt schon wieder Berner Platte.
D.h., der Herbst ist da.
Hoi, Regine.
Für ihre Familie
kauft Schläpfer im Dorfladen ein.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Geld Sie
für Essen, Kleider und Ausgehen,
also soziales Leben,
pro Monat brauchen?
Ich?
- Ja.
Nein, das weiss ich nicht.
- Ist es mehr als der Grundbedarf?
Ich denke nicht, nein.
Ich bin eine sehr Sparsame.
Sie sehen, ich brauche nur
einen Sack für drei, vier Sachen.
Ich würde nun mal behaupten,
man käme durch.
Also wie gesagt,
bei 600 Fr. ist es der Ansporn,
dass man aufs Geld achtet.
Sie könnten sich einen Monat lang
aufschreiben, wie viel Sie brauchen,
ob die 600 Fr. reichen.
Essen, Kleider, Ausgehen.
Kleider brauche ich auch kaum.
Therese Schläpfer
ist dreifache Mutter
und hat immer Teilzeit gearbeitet,
meist bei ihrem Mann im Geschäft.
Jetzt ist
die ehemalige Flight Attendant
zu 20 %
als Gemeindepräsidentin tätig.
Ich bin in der glücklichen Lage,
dass ich
unseren Volg unterstützen kann.
Ich habe ja auch nicht so viel Zeit,
um den Aktionen nachzurennen,
denn ich arbeite ja noch.
Die Gemeindepräsidentin
nimmt unseren Vorschlag auf
und wird persönlich prüfen,
was es heisst,
mit einem gekürzten Grundbedarf
zu leben.
Auch Felix Wolffers ist,
je nach Fall,
für Druck, Kontrolle und Sanktionen.
Stolz ist Wolffers aber
auf die Bemühungen der Stadt Bern,
die Sozialhilfebezüger
wieder zu integrieren.
Der Leiter des Sozialamts
führt uns zu einer
der Velostationen am Bahnhof.
Hier erhalten Sozialhilfeempfänger,
die auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt keine
Chance haben, eine Tagesstruktur.
Seit Kurzem arbeiten auch vorläufig
aufgenommene Asylbewerber hier.
Tatsache ist einfach,
dass viele Leute
aus dem Asyl- oder Migrationsbereich
früher oder später
in die Sozialhilfe kommen.
Wir finden es wichtig,
dass die möglichst früh
in die Arbeitswelt kommen.
Deswegen beschäftigen wir hier
gezielt Leute aus dem Asylbereich.
Was kann ich machen?
Jeylani Samadi ist einer
von aktuell drei Asylbewerbern,
die hier einen Job haben.
Samadi kommt aus Afghanistan und
ist seit drei Jahren in der Schweiz.
Mittlerweile ist er
vorläufig aufgenommener Ausländer.
Noch übernehmen Bund und Kanton
seine Sozialhilfekosten.
Wenn er in ein paar Jahren
keine Arbeit findet,
muss der Sozialdienst der Gemeinde
übernehmen.
Ich bin Lastwagenmechaniker.
Ich habe diese Arbeit in meinem
Land, in Afghanistan, gelernt.
Ich habe Interesse,
mit meinen Händen zu arbeiten.
Jetzt Velo.
Ich flicke Velos, ja.
Er ist der erste Flüchtling,
für den ich mich eingesetzt habe,
dass er hier
eine Vorlehre machen kann.
Er ist ausserordentlich motiviert
und arbeitet gut.
Er spricht sehr gut Deutsch - ein
Traumkandidat, den ich selten habe.
Längst nicht alle
packen so an wie Jeylani Samadi.
V.a. Leute, die der Sozialdienst
der Stadt Bern vermittelt,
hätten manchmal Probleme und seien
unpünktlich, sagt Martin Tschachtli.
Ein-, zweimal rufe ich an,
dann ist der Einsatz abgebrochen.
Denn das sind Sachen,
die nicht gehen.
Das können Sie nirgends bringen.
Dich musste ich noch nie anrufen,
oder?
Nein.
Wenn jemand nicht will,
dann will er einfach nicht.
Aber .. ähm ...
ob es dann gleich richtig ist,
die Sparschraube
über alle anzusetzen,
das ist eine andere Frage.
Es trifft in der Regel die Falschen.
Jeylani Samadi hat Feierabend.
Er sei zufällig
in der Schweiz gelandet,
habe flüchten müssen wegen des
Krieges und der Taliban, sagt er.
Den genauen Grund
kennt nur das Migrationsamt.
Seit einem halben Jahr
wohnt er nun in Niederscherli,
einem Vorort von Bern.
Hey, wie geht es dir?
- Gut. Und dir?
Samadi
wohnt zusammen mit Vali Haydari.
Auch er ist aus Afghanistan
und seit drei Jahren in der Schweiz.
Manchmal koche ich, manchmal er.
Heute habe ich Ocra gekocht.
Das ist afghanisches Essen.
Das ist auch sehr gesund
und sehr lecker.
Bist du fertig?
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Ah, okay. Sorry.
- Schon okay.
Wie viel kostet die Wohnung?
Etwa 640 Fr. pro Monat.
Durch zwei?
- Ja.
Ist gut?
Kennengelernt haben sich
die beiden Afghanen im Asylzentrum.
Jeylani ist 25, Vali 27 Jahre alt.
Das ist Valis Zimmer
und wir essen normalerweise hier.
Jetzt in der Schweiz
habe ich nur ihn.
Nur ihn. Genau.
Danke, ich auch. Ich bin stolz
auf dich, dass ich dich habe.
Sie leben noch von der Sozialhilfe.
- Ja.
Wie viel? 400 Fr.?
Genau.
Ich bekomme pro Monat ca. 400 fr.
Und wie geht das?
Es geht. Es ist wenig,
aber was soll ich machen?
Als vorläufig aufgenommener Ausländer
erhält Samadi 412 Fr.
für den Grundbedarf.
Im Asylbereich sind die Ansätze
generell deutlich tiefer
als in der regulären Sozialhilfe.
Für seine Arbeit in der Velostation
bekommt Samadi zusätzlich 561 Fr.
Bald will er eine Lehre antreten
und mehr verdienen.
Kollege Vali hat es bereits geschafft
und ist weg von der Sozialhilfe.
Seit Kurzem
arbeitet er in einem Altersheim.
Das ist aussergewöhnlich.
Rund 80 % der Asylbewerber
leben von der Sozialhilfe.
Mehr Druck sei nicht falsch,
sagen beide.
Etwas Druck: "Lernt Deutsch, lernt!"
Man muss etwas machen -
eine Vorlehre, ein Praktikum,
keine Ahnung,
einen Deutschkurs besuchen.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn man in der Schweiz bleiben
will, muss man die Sprache können.
Im Gegensatz zu Flüchtlingen
wurde die Sozialhilfe
bei Asylbewerber und
vorläufig aufgenommenen Ausländern
vor drei Jahren gekürzt.
Luzern. Hier will Karin de Roche
billig einkaufen.
Mit dabei ist einer der Hunde,
die sie in Freiwilligenarbeit für
eine Tierschutzorganisation betreut.
1 Std. dauert die Zugfahrt
von Mosen hierher.
Es nimmt viel Zeit weg.
Und wenn man nicht so viel Geld hat,
13 Fr. fürs Tagesbillett ...
Das mache ich im Monat
ein- bis zweimal.
Der Caritas-Markt
verkauft vergünstigt Ware,
die für die reguläre Kundschaft
nicht mehr infrage kommt.
Manchmal sind es auch
abgelaufene Produkte.
Verkaufen dürfen sie sie nicht mehr,
aber wir dürfen es noch essen.
Ich schaue wegen der Preise,
was günstiger kommt.
Eine kostet 70 Rp., die 95 Rp. -
ich brauche etwa fünf.
Das Viererpack für 3 Fr.
Rechnen?
- Immer.
Gibt es manchmal auch Glücksfälle?
- Manchmal.
Welche?
- Je nachdem.
Das, was die Kinder mögen. Manchmal
haben sie Ovo-Produkte in Aktion.
Aber sonst sind sie auch hier teuer,
dann kaufe ich sie auch nicht.
Günstiger als eine Tafel Schokolade.
Ab und zu haben die Kinder Freude,
auch wenn nicht mehr Ostern ist.
Nur wer nachweislich arm ist,
darf hier einkaufen.
Es braucht eine Bescheinigung.
Grüezi, darf ich bitte rasch
die Karte sehen? Danke vielmals.
Danke schön.
Das Thema Sparen
beherrscht den Alltag.
Es bringt nichts, zu überlegen,
ob es einem verleidet.
Es gibt gute und schlechte Tage.
Ein schlechter Tag ist,
wenn der Kühlschrank leer ist.
Ein guter ist, wenn er voll ist.
Therese Schläpfer
hat inzwischen eigenhändig berechnet,
was es täglich
zum Überleben braucht.
Also, das ist mein Selbstversuch mit
einem Einkauf in unserem Dorfladen.
Tagesbedarf: das Mittagessen
besteht aus Salat, Gemüse, Fleisch,
Beilagen, Dessert und Kaffee -
Total 6.50 Fr.
Für einen Tag rechnet Schläpfer total
mit 12.50 Fr.
für Essen und Trinken pro Person.
Den restlichen Bedarf für den Lebens-
unterhalt berechnet sie noch hinzu
und unterbietet gar das absolute
Existenzminimum von 690 Fr.
Posten wie Strom oder Mobilität
hat sie allerdings
ausser Acht gelassen.
Ich bin jetzt auf 433.20 Fr.
gekommen mit Körperpflege, Handy ...
... Lebensmittel ...
Möchten Sie so leben?
Nein, darum arbeite ich ja.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen zynisch?
Nein ... ähm ...
Zynisch ...
Ich sage ja: Sicher gibt es Leute,
die in eine Notsituation kommen.
Das ist uns allen klar.
Und denen soll man helfen.
Das ist auch klar.
Aber dieser Betrag soll zeigen,
dass man auch mit einem Drittel
weniger von 986 Fr. gut durchkommt.
Rückfahrt vom Caritas-Markt.
Wir geben Karin de Roche
die Einkaufsliste,
die Therese Schläpfer
zusammengestellt hat.
1.56 Fr. fürs Frühstück,
6.50 Fr. fürs Mittagessen
und 3.05 Fr. fürs Abendessen.
Sehr preiswert. Wo findet sie das?
Ich finde es irritierend.
Es ist seltsam berechnet.
Etwas realitätsfern,
würde ich sagen.
2 dl Orangensaft für 37 Rp.?
Vom Fleisch rede ich gar nicht erst.
95 Rp.
Das Bier könnte hinkommen,
aber der Rest - nein.
Und mit Bier
kann ich mich schlecht ernähren.
Ich finde es schlimm.
Man kann noch viel
aufs Papier schreiben,
aber in der Realität
sieht es anders aus.
Ich würde gern
mit ihr einkaufen gehen.
Sie nimmt mich bei der Hand
und zeigt mir das.
Einkaufen mit Therese Schläpfer.
Bald soll dieser Wunsch
in Erfüllung gehen.
Monika Senn hat nur z.T.
Recht bekommen mit ihrer Beschwerde.
Das Sozialamt müsse Rücksicht nehmen
auf ihre chronischen Schmerzen
und die Kündigungsfrist beachten.
Aber der Umzug in eine günstigere
Wohnung ist unumgänglich -
wenn nötig ausserhalb der Gemeinde.
Ich habe da eine 2-Zimmerwohnung
und eine 1-Zimmerwohnung gesehen,
und dann steht da:
"keine Sozialhilfeempfänger".
Bei beiden Inseraten.
Man wird traurig.
Und mit der Zeit
kriegt man auch so eine Wut.
Es ist eine Hilflosigkeit da.
Schon im Frühling 2020
kommt Monika Senn ins Pensionsalter.
Mit AHV und Ergänzungsleistungen
könnte sie sich
die bisherige Wohnung leisten.
Die Gemeinde aber
will konsequent bleiben.
Es gibt eine Richtlinie.
Wir behandeln vom Jüngsten
bis zum Ältesten alle gleich.
Der einzelne Fall des
Sozialhilfebezügers wird angeschaut,
damit er nicht besser dasteht
als jemand, der arbeitet.
Sind diese Massnahmen, die Sie
jetzt treffen oder getroffen haben,
kostenwirksam?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Weil
so viele Sozialfälle hinzukamen,
ist es noch schwierig zu sagen,
ob wir Kosten senken konnten.
Aber wir freuen uns über jeden,
den wir in den ersten Arbeitsmarkt
eingliedern können,
weil er uns dann weniger kostet.
Die medizinische Diagnose,
die das Sozialamt verlangt hat,
ist für Monika Senn
ungünstig ausgefallen.
Sie sei zu 100 % arbeitsfähig,
wenn sie sich
am Arbeitsplatz bewegen könne.
Dass das gleich 100 % ist,
das hat mich erstaunt.
Denn die Schmerzen
haben ziemlich zugenommen.
Die Gemeinde prüft nun,
ob sie Monika Senn in die
Arbeitsintegration schicken will.
In ihrem Alter sind die Chancen auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt verschwindend klein.
Die Zahl der älteren Menschen
in der Sozialhilfe
hat sich in den letzten Jahren
verdoppelt.
Ich bin überzeugt, die wollen,
dass ich wegziehe vom Dorf,
damit sie Kosten sparen können.
Dann müsste ein anderes Sozialamt
in einem anderen Dorf
meinen Lebensunterhalt
und meine Miete übernehmen.
Ich glaube wirklich,
das ist der Grund.
Paragraphenreiterei ohne Augenmass.
Oder gerechtfertigter Druck?
Ein typischer Konflikt zwischen
Sozialhilfeempfängerin und Gemeinde.
Langwierig,
nervenaufreibend, unbefriedigend.
Die Sozialhilfe hat ein Problem,
dass die Kantone
die Regelungen machen
und die Gemeinden
finanzieren müssen.
Das erhöht bei Gemeinden
mit hoher Sozialhilfequote
den finanziellen Druck
in grossem Stil.
Und das gibt Druck
auf die Sozialhilfe.
Und eigentlich wäre es richtig,
wenn man die Sozialhilfe
wie bei den Sozialversicherungen
vom Bund regeln würde und einen
fairen Verteilmechanismus definiert
für die Kosten,
damit nicht einzelne Gemeinden
übermässig betroffen sind
und andere gar nicht.
Therese Schläpfer will nicht,
dass sich der Bund einmischt.
Im Gegenteil, sie fordert mehr
Handlungsspielraum für die Gemeinden.
Wenn der Sozialhilfebezüger
zuerst Motivation und Kooperation
zeigen müsse,
bevor er
die volle Unterstützung erhalte,
sei das effizienter
als das heutige Strafsystem.
Warum reizt es so,
die Schraube derart anzuziehen?
Erstens:
Man hat praktisch keine Handhabe
bzw. es ist schwierig und harzig,
Leistungen zu kürzen.
Ich möchte nicht
von Bestrafung sprechen.
Wenn sie nicht kooperieren, dass man
ihnen die Leistungen kürzen kann.
Das kann man heute.
- Ja.
Aber es wäre den Steuerzahlern
gegenüber sicher fairer,
wenn man
mit den arbeitsfähigen Leuten
tiefer anfangen könnte
in der Sozialhilfe.
Therese Schläpfer fühlt sich bestärkt
von einer Studie des Bundes,
wonach weniger Sozialhilfegeld
v.a. junge Menschen
zur Arbeit bewegen kann.
Felix Wolffers hat viele Anpassungen
in der Sozialhilfe mitgestaltet.
Jetzt ist er aber müde.
Seit fünf Jahren
ist er Co-Präsident der SKOS,
seit zehn Jahren
Chef des Berner Sozialamts.
In dieser Zeit wurde
die politische Diskussion härter.
Immer wieder gab es Schlagzeilen
zum Sozialhilfemissbrauch.
Begründet oder unbegründet.
Der letzte Sturm der Entrüstung:
Bei einer Sozialhilfebezügerin
wurden nach dem Tod
Säcke voller Kleider gefunden.
Obwohl sich der Fall
als haltlos erweisen sollte,
war Wolffers tagelang gefordert.
Also wir haben festgestellt, dass
das Dossier korrekt geführt wurde.
Wir haben keine Anhaltspunkte
auf einen Sozialhilfemissbrauch.
Da ist gar nichts dran.
Darüber rede ich nicht.
- Aber welche Auswirkungen ...
Ich will nicht,
dass man den erwähnt.
Der ist so schräg.
Auch wenn ich irgendwas sage,
bin ich sofort in der Defensive.
Das mag ich nicht.
Die Berner Sozialdirektion
reichte wegen dieses Falls
beim Presserat Beschwerde ein
und bekam vollumfänglich Recht:
Der Presserat rügte den "Blick"
u.a. wegen
Verletzung der Wahrheitspflicht.
Die Berichterstattung über diesen
Fall sei spekulativ und unwahr,
die Grenze des Zulässigen
überschritten.
Immer neue Skandal-Schlagzeilen
und ständiger Spardruck -
Wolffers hat genug.
Er hat seinen Rücktritt
als SKOS-Präsident angekündigt.
Je mehr
solche Kürzungsvorschläge kommen,
die keine sachliche Basis haben,
desto schwieriger wird es,
die Diskussion zu führen, denn es
kommen keine sachlichen Argumente.
Es kommen Vorschläge: 30 % weniger.
Es gibt aber keine sachliche Basis.
Das macht es
extrem schwierig für mich.
Ich bin einer,
der gerne sachlich diskutiert.
Aber die sachliche Diskussion fehlt.
Darum bin ich nun an einem Punkt,
an dem ich das
nicht mehr weitermachen kann.
Ich gebe dieses Amt gerne ab
und werde mich weiterhin
in anderer Form einsetzen.
Sind Sie zermürbt?
Nein.
Aber es ist eine doppelte Belastung.
Es ist eine zeitliche Belastung
und auch eine emotionale Belastung.
Ciao, hallo.
Bis im Mai ist Felix Wolffers
an der Seite von Therese Frösch
noch im Amt
als Co-Präsident der SKOS.
An der Jahresmedienkonferenz in Bern
präsentieren die beiden eine Studie,
die zeigt, wie viel das Leben wirk-
lich kostet für die Ärmsten im Land.
Mit Fakten will die SKOS
den Kürzungsvorschlägen
in den Kantonen entgegentreten.
Eine solch detaillierte Analyse
gab es bisher nicht.
Die Frage ist ja einfach:
"Wie weit kann man
mit solchen Kürzungen gehen?"
Da gibt es
auch rechtliche Schranken.
Die Kantone sind verpflichtet,
die Grundrechte zu gewährleisten.
Sie müssen eine menschenwürdige
Existenz sichern.
Man kann nicht aus finanzpolitischen
oder anderen Gründen
beliebig tiefe Grundbedarfswerte
ansetzen.
Der Grundbedarf orientiert sich
an den 10 %
der einkommensschwächsten Haushalte.
Die SKOS-Studie kommt zum Schluss:
Schon der aktuelle Grundbedarf
reicht nur knapp zum Leben.
Rein rechnerisch
müsste er höher liegen.
Kürzungen seien nicht vertretbar.
Wenn man schaut:
Was heisst eine 30-%-Kürzung
bei der Sozialhilfe im Grundbedarf?
Dann stehen
einer vierköpfigen Familie
noch 5 Fr. pro Tag zur Verfügung
für Nahrung und Getränke.
Niemand hier kann für 5 Fr. pro Tag
gesund und vernünftig leben.
5 Fr. pro Tag und Kopf
für Essen und Trinken -
das stimme nicht, sagen die beiden
Baselbieter SVP-Politiker
Kurt Riebli und Andi Trüssel.
Es sei alles
eine Frage der Einteilung.
Man könne z.B. mehr fürs Essen
und weniger fürs Handy ausgeben.
30 % weniger Sozialhilfe sei machbar.
Wir müssen einfach aufpassen,
dass wir mit der früheren Fürsorge,
der Sozialhilfe,
kein zweites Rentensystem einführen.
Die Leute müssten
möglichst rasch wieder raus.
Mich wundert einfach, dass die SKOS
bei ihren Richtlinien sagt:
"Wir haben
30 % Reduktionsmöglichkeit,
wenn sich jemand
nicht konform verhält."
Und dann
soll das immer noch gut sein.
Aber wenn wir
bei -30 % starten wollen
und Motivierte
auf 100 % bringen wollen,
dann ist das menschenunwürdig.
Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Für die SKOS
ist die Kürzung um 30 %
nur als zeitlich
begrenzte Sanktion zulässig.
Mit ihrer aktuellen Studie
will sie die politische Diskussion
versachlichen.
Das Problem sind die Kantone,
die jetzt radikale
Kürzungsvorschläge diskutieren.
Es kann dazu führen,
dass das System auseinanderbricht.
Und was dann passiert,
wissen wir nicht.
Sozialhilfebezügerin Karin de Roche
in Hagenbuch.
Gemeindepräsidentin Therese Schläpfer
hat zu einem gemeinsamen Testeinkauf
eingewilligt,
um ihre Liste zu erklären.
Grüezi. Schläpfer.
- De Roche. - Freut mich.
Karin de Roche will v.a. wissen,
wie sich die günstigen Preise
auf der Liste zusammensetzen.
Gut, Volg hat natürlich
auch immer Aktionen.
Dann könnte man sich auch
ein bisschen darauf ausrichten.
Für mich im Alltag
ist es nicht realistisch.
Und der Käse ...
Was man wirklich braucht ...
Keine Ahnung,
wie Sie auf diese Zahlen kommen.
Ein Stück Käse à 30 g pro Tag
zum Preis von 40 Rp.
hat Therese Schläpfer z.B. berechnet.
Wo gibt es diese kleinen Portionen?
Wo diesen günstigen Käse?
Das Kilo kostet 14 Fr.
Das ist ein sehr guter Käse.
Den kaufe ich auch noch oft.
Und den teile ich mir dann ein?
Das sind in etwa die Portionen,
die man braucht.
Er ist nicht geschnitten,
das ist klar.
Z.B. auch Restaurants
berechnen es so.
Ich müsste das Anfang Monat kaufen,
damit das einigermassen aufgeht,
damit es wirklich diese Preise sind.
Das sind einzelne Produkte, die
halt mal 20 oder 30 Rp. mehr kosten.
Aber ...
Dann stehe ich mit meinen 12.50 Fr.
da und hatte Pech.
Auch wenn die Rechnung auf dieser
Liste für Therese Schläpfer aufgeht:
Karin de Roche lehnt sie ab.
Untauglich für den Alltag, sagt sie.
Und die ganzen Kürzungsvorschläge
ein Treten nach unten.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass ich dann noch weniger kriege
oder einfach mal
unter Generalverdacht stehe
und beweisen muss,
dass ich nichts falsch mache,
nur weil ich abhängig bin von
der Sozialhilfe, ist das schlimm.
Generalverdacht ...
Ich verstehe jetzt nicht,
was Sie meinen.
Es wird gekürzt und ich muss
beweisen, dass mir das Geld zusteht.
Sie wären aber ausgenommen,
weil Sie ein ...
Ich kann ja auch arbeiten.
Aber Sie müssen
ein behindertes Kind betreuen.
Sie können also nicht arbeiten.
Sie fallen sowieso
aus der Gruppe ...
Er ist unter der Woche
ein paar Tage weg.
Man könnte mich zwingen,
ein paar Tage zu arbeiten.
Also zwingen ... Man macht Ihnen
sicher den Vorschlag ...
Den Vorschlag. Genau.
... dass sie
Arbeit suchen während dieser Zeit.
Die geplanten Kürzungen würden Leute
wie Karin de Roche nicht treffen,
sagt Therese Schläpfer.
Doch die Pläne aus dem Baselbiet
sind klar.
In einem ersten Schritt
gäbe es für alle weniger.
Die Bedürftigen
müssten sich dann beweisen.
Ja, so den Grundgedanken,
wie man auf das kommt -
das verstehe ich.
Ich mache das auch mit den Kindern:
Wenn eines unartig war,
bestrafe ich beide.
Obwohl es nicht okay ist.
Ich verstehe das.
Das ist dann nicht so ...
- Es ist nicht okay.
In dem Moment bin ich unfair,
weil ich nicht
das betroffene Kind bestrafe.
Wir wollen fair sein, alle abklären.
- Alle bestrafen, genau.
Nicht bestrafen, sondern ...
- Es ist eine Bestrafung.
Die Sozialhilfeempfänger fühlen sich
abgestraft, die Gemeinden ohnmächtig.
Der Finanzdruck
macht sie zu Gegenspielern.
Oder: Geht es gar nicht nur ums Geld?
Ist es grundsätzlich
schwer zu akzeptieren,
dass jemand Geld bekommt,
ohne dafür zu arbeiten?
In diesem Jahr fallen in den Kantonen
wegweisende Entscheide,
wie viel Sozialhilfeempfänger
haben dürfen.